i would also recommend not using it
first thing in the morning because if
you wake up and you instantly look at
your inbox and you have like
you know 30 unread emails and you're
just like um my god i'm so behind
as soon as you wake up it turns out if
you limit the time you spend doing it
you it doesn't limit
productivity these are not easy shifts
to make but it makes me feel better if i
kind of
shift and start my morning a little bit
late so that i can
spend time with my kid meditate and
exercise
and then i can dive into work and i'm so
much more productive that way that it
makes up for the
you know two hours i didn't do that in
the morning